hey guys it's Jonah here so I recently
went to Bangkok for a short trip with my
girlfriends and the highlights of my
trip was enjoying fresh and tasty Thai
food filled with vegetables the secret
to good food really comes down to using
simple and fresh ingredients which is
basically the inspiration behind this
video so I'm going to share with you not
one but eight variations of a lettuce
wrap ideas which are light fresh crunchy
nutritious and bursting with flavors all
these recipes are under 100 calories and
make the perfect Sun snack
they are extremely easy and quick to put
together so be sure to watch to the end
of this video for the full recipes
let's start cooking chicken and mango
salsa makes the perfect combination as a
light and refreshing starter for the
filling you need 4 ounce of baked
chicken breasts diced into small cubes
1/2 a medium mango puked and diced into
small cubes 1/2 a medium cucumber diced
into small cubes 1 medium spring onion
thinly sliced a handful of coriander
roughly chopped to make the dressing
you need juice from one lime 1/2 a tbsp
of sesame oil and 1/2 a tbsp of honey in
a small bowl combine lime juice sesame
oil and honey set aside in a large bowl
add chicken breast cubes mango cucumber
spring onion and coriander combine well
toss in the dressing and mix until
evenly coated to assemble spoon generous
amount of chicken and mango salsa
mixture onto lettuce leaves you'll bite
into the natural sweetness from the
mango and crunchiness from the cucumber
so refreshing and light next is a
combination of beans and sweet potato
absolutely yummy and great for vegans
for the feeling you need have a can of
black beans rinsed and drained or any
other beans of your choice 1 large sweet
potato baked and diced into small cubes
cut a medium red onion finely diced
a handful of coriander roughly chopped
and salt and pepper to taste to make the
dressing
you need juice from one line 1/2 a
tablespoon of olive oil 1/2 a teaspoon
of cumin and half a teaspoon of smoked
paprika in a small bowl combine lime
juice olive oil cumin and smoked paprika
set aside in a large bowl add black
beans sweet potato red onion and
coriander combine well toss in the
dressing and season with salt and pepper
mix until evenly coated spoon generous
amount of black beans and sweet potato
mixture onto lettuce leaves so simple
and yummy if you're a vegan and you
enjoy Asian flavors then make this spicy
tofu mushroom lettuce wraps for the
filling you need one packet of firm tofu
drained and cut into small cubes 1 cup
of button mushroom chopped 1/2 a medium
red bell pepper diced into cubes a
handful of fresh coriander finely sliced
quarter cup of cashew nuts crushed 2
small red chili this seeded and finely
sliced and 1/2 a tbsp of sesame oil to
make the dressing you'll need juice from
one line 2 tablespoons of soy sauce and
1 tbsp of water in a small bowl combine
lime juice soy sauce and water set aside
heat sesame oil over medium-high heat
add mushroom and cook for 2 to 3 minutes
until slightly tender add tofu and sear
until lightly Brown for another 2 to 3
minutes on each side
toss in red bell pepper chili and cashew
nuts cook very quickly for another 1
minute and stir in the soya sauce
mixture continue cooking for another 2
to 3 minutes until sauce has reduced
slightly remove from heat and allow it
to cool down to serve spoon generous
amount of tofu mixture onto lettuce
leaves and sprinkle with coriander tofu
is a great source of protein for vegans
and
drum is packed with vitamin D and the
hint of chilli adds a nice twist to the
dish next is another Asian flavored
lettuce wrap with my all-time favorite
protein smoked salmon for the filling
you'll need 100 gram of smoked salmon
sliced 1/2 a cup of carrots shredded 1/2
a cup of cucumber shredded and half a
cup of cherry tomatoes haft to make the
dressing you'll need juice from one line
half a tablespoon of fish sauce half a
tablespoon of honey quarter cup of
jalapeno thinly sliced and one medium
spring onion thinly sliced in a bowl
combine spring onions jalapenos lime
juice fish sauce and honey allow the
ingredients to marinate for 15 minutes
and room temperature in a large bowl add
smoked salmon carrots cucumber and
cherry tomatoes combined well toss in
the dressing and mix until evenly coated
spoon generous amount of smoked salmon
mixture onto lettuce leaves and serve no
cooking is required for this recipe so
this makes a very nutritious and
convenient dish faith yummy lettuce wrap
is creamy tuna and corn for the filling
you need 1 can of tuna chunks drained
1/2 a cup of whole cords cooked half a
medium red bell pepper diced into cubes
cut a cup of olives sliced 1 medium
spring onion thinly sliced and salt and
pepper to taste to make the dressing
it's only two ingredients cut a cup of
plain yogurt and juice from half a lemon
in a small bowl combine yogurt and lemon
juice set aside in a large bowl add tuna
chunks cones red bell pepper olives and
spring onion combine well toss in the
dressing and season with salt and pepper
mix until evenly coated to serve spoon
generous amount of tuna and corn mixture
onto lettuce leaves the simple
combination of tuna and corn can never
go wrong and the natural criminis of
yogurt brings this dish
next is a Mexican inspired vegan quinoa
and black bean wrap this dish is so
colorful it's bursting with flavors and
extremely easy to make even the quinoa
is cooked right in the pan
you need half a cup of uncooked quinoa
half a can of black beans rinsed and
drained 1 medium tomato de seeded and
diced into cubes 1/2 a cup of Hawkins
cooked half an avocado diced 2 garlic
cloves minced quarter cup of jalapenos
thinly sliced 1 cup of water a handful
of fresh coriander roughly chopped juice
from one lime 1/2 a tbsp of olive oil 1
teaspoon of chili powder 1/2 a teaspoon
of cumin and salt and pepper to taste in
a pan hits olive oil over medium-high
heat add garlic and jalapenos cooked
very quickly for about 1 minute until
fragrant stir in quinoa water black
beans tomatoes corn chili powder and
cumin season with salt and pepper bring
to a boil cover reduce heat and simmer
until quinoa is cooked through this will
take about 12 to 15 minutes once quinoa
is cooked turn off the heat and stir in
the avocado lime juice and coriander
remove from heat and allow the quinoa to
cool down slightly spoon generous amount
of quinoa mixture onto lettuce leaf this
dish is bursting with so many amazing
flavors you get the hint of spice from
the chili powder and jalapeno criminals
from the avocado cooked with quinoa one
of the world's healthiest foods so so
good well if you have tried my egg and
avocado breakfast
let's take it a notch up and make this
yummy garlic stream and egg with avocado
lettuce wrap you need 20 medium sized
shrimps 2 eggs hot boy and finely sliced
half an avocado mashed 2 garlic cloves
minced 1 TSP of olive oil and salt and
pepper to taste in a pan heat olive oil
over medium-high heat
add garlic and toss very quickly for
one-minutes anti fragrance and lightly
brown then tossing the shrimps and cook
for about two to three minutes and two
shrimps are just pink on both side do
not overcook or they'll be dry and hard
set aside and allow the streams to cool
down slightly in a large bowl add
shrimps eggs and mashed avocado season
with salt and pepper combine well to
serve spoon generous amount of stream
and egg mixture onto lettuce leaves I
love garlic shrimps and that mixed with
eggs and avocado is just a perfect match
you have to try it and finally it has to
be a bite of a refreshing tropical fruit
salad for the filling you need half a
cup of cherry tomatoes heart one small
green apple sliced into cubes 1 medium
Kiwi sliced 1/2 a cup of pineapple diced
into cubes quarter cup of dried
cranberries and 2 tablespoons of cashew
nuts crushed as for the dressing only
two ingredients cut a cup of plain
yogurt and juice from half eleven to
make the dressing combine yogurt and
lemon juice set aside in a large bowl
add cherry tomatoes green apple kiwi
pineapple dried cranberries and cashew
nuts combine well toss in the dressing
and mix until evenly coated spoon
generous amount of fruit mixture onto
lettuce leaves and serve all these
lettuce wrap fillings can be served
immediately after cooking or chilled
you can store the left over in the
fridge and it will last up to three days
they are wonderfully light nutritious
and absolutely delicious I made eight
variations just for you so that you can
make one a day have them as a snack
starter or even as your main meal
lettuce wrap is a great
I'm going to add more greens into your
diet so be sure to try them out make
them for your family and friends and let
me know which is your favorite in the
comments below
all the best mmm so good
you